[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Eli Manning won a couple
of Super Bowls Of course one of the
stars of the Manning cast joining us on
behalf of Quaker Oats which we'll get to
coming up in a moment Eli good to see
you twice in a month how great is that
um no this is awesome yeah you're like a
member of the team or I feel like I'm a
member of the Manning family here so
this is good
um how is roughing the passer changed in
the last let's say 15 years
I think it's yeah it used to be just
about uh just the timing like kind of
hey the ball is released you had like
was it within a step if he takes two
steps and then hits you
um you know it would be you know
roughing the passer
um you know then it kind of changed and
said no hits to the to the helmet and
which you know trying to with the
concussions everything all made sense
hey you can't just dive you can't even
have your hand hit the helmet and then
it's kind of turned into the you know
driving into the ground uh eliminating
that
um but you know it's it's hard and I
think anytime you start
um you know kind of getting hey the
Judgment did he drive into him did he
hit into him guys were competitive
they're trying to strap you know strip
the ball sack make sure they wrap up but
and make a tackle it's uh I see it it's
hard hard on the defense hard on the
refs on some of these calls
um you know you can go super slow mo and
see hey you did didn't really drive into
them or can you toss them can you swing
them you know it's very judgmental and I
think it's hard to hard to officiate
okay would you be in favor of Replay
um I think you could I I think I'd be in
favor of Replay to see whether hey that
was that was truly a um
uh you know a foul uh just because it's
such a big play a lot I mean I think a
lot of the times it's it's third down
and you know it's whether you know it's
like a turnover basically it's whether
hey you're getting the ball back or 15
yards first down I mean that's a huge
play you get someone extra 15 yards and
a first down I think you know the
chances of points being scored is going
to go way up after that and so um I'd be
okay with replay just because it it
becomes such a huge play
the past you had to David Tyree wouldn't
have happened
you would have been in the grass they
probably would have tried to protect you
I'm going to guess no I don't think so I
don't know
I think before
fourth quarter Super Bowl two minute
drive uh you know I don't think they're
gonna call in in the grass right there
at that moment I think they would know
I'd be willing to take a hit for a few
extra an extra second to get out of
there once again people call it the
catch and I call it the throw the
scramble so but so just want to let you
know but is there preferential treatment
that we see this with the NBA
we see this with baseball sometimes with
pitchers uh or batters is there
preferential treatment when it comes to
calls in the NFL well
I mean I think of it this way of like
you know I mean Brady he's just he's 44.
he's not 22. he's like you know he's an
old man out there you're kind of like oh
that's gonna hurt him he looks a little
frail you know it's not like Josh Allen
who's like 250 pounds and you know it's
like you can't toss him around you can't
move him that much and so you know maybe
with the a smaller guy it looks like
it's a much bigger hit and therefore
they can call call a grounding but um
you know I think it's like hey we gotta
take care of this guy he's been been
around we don't want to get hurt so I I
don't think there is like on purpose I
don't think a ref say hey I'm gonna I'm
Really Gonna protect this guy just it
just might look differently uh a hit on
some quarterbacks than others
what is Brady four years older than you
uh yeah I think four three or four isn't
that weird that you know you're you're
sitting here talking to us and Brady is
still playing he's still playing he was
playing yeah he was playing when I got
into the NFL and he's you know playing
long after I left the NFL and I I
consider I you know played a long time
and so uh and he's playing well playing
at a high level and uh so you know give
him a ton a ton of credit and uh he's
he's uh uh it's amazing so he's doing
he's doing he's got some good genes he's
doing something right in his his
preparation and and uh keeping his body
safe and not and not getting hit not
getting injured and be able to heal
quickly so it's uh there's a lot of
things that he's doing that are that are
truly impressive okay how long did it
take you to get ready to be Chad powers
and how was your body after Chad Powers
uh tryout it took two hours of makeup
two hours of makeup of just sitting
there but how about the arm how long did
it take that together no the arm Chad
you know you can't shed the arm it's
good so it's it's strong it was ready
yeah and so that that part wasn't uh I
wasn't worried about the throwing part
the 40 I was you know I was a little
worried about but I knew like hey I can
just I can cruise through a 40 and and
you know even though I'm I'm saying
think fast run fast I'm thinking don't
pull a hammy don't pull a hammy don't
pull hammy so that that wasn't you know
I wasn't I didn't come out with a big
burst but I was worried about was the 5
10 5 shuttle drill I mean that's kind of
where you you got to get low you got to
touch the ground I mean that's that's
some cutting involved that's where you
you you you twist an ankle you do
something there
um and I you know I knew I had to throw
after doing all these things which was
going to be the entertaining part of
this whole show so I'm like I just gotta
get to the throwing part where I can you
know get with the coach and start
talking and and get through some of
these make up some stories about Chad
okay but who are you channeling
who who is Chad powers in your mind that
I'm going to try to be him when I'm in
this character you know I I I I don't I
don't even know I think it's just
someone who uh I mean it's a little bit
I mean his Uncle Kenny Powers definitely
had an influence on him
um you know I think uh his uncle Austin
Powers also probably a little influence
so I mean I think those two guys you
know have have played a big part in
Chad's life and just you know growing up
and watching them as Role Models so
um you know but I think it's just more
you know it's just I I didn't know what
was going to happen I didn't know what
was going to you know come out uh and
luckily you know it just it got you know
it's just kind of I was quiet really the
first 30 minutes of the whole shoot I
didn't really say anything I didn't want
to come in and and people would be
looking at me I knew I was gonna look
ridiculous all all ready and be older
than everybody and just kind of be like
who's this guy but I wanted to say hey
this you know this guy's here to work
and he's just doing the drills and doing
everything and then once I kind of you
know got with the throwing part got with
the coach and he was curious about who I
was and started asking questions that's
that's when I started making up stories
and kind of got a little confidence and
a little cocky and and uh and started
you know having some fun uh tell us what
you're doing with Quaker Oats yeah
excited to partner up with uh with
Quaker Oaks and and um you know uh with
Quaker really because one I love oatmeal
I've been the last 15 years I've had it
almost every every morning of my life
and and so I'm a big fan but also
um like Quaker I believe that the
circumstances of life should never be a
barrier to good nutrition so a part of
uh Quaker's commitment to help Advance
food Security in the U.S they are
introducing the Quaker hunger clot in
partnership with feeding America and
their goal is to raise five hundred
thousand dollars uh by Super Bowl 57
um and so you know that's beginning this
weekend you can go to
quakerhungerclock.com to find out how
you can learn more information and to
donate uh to feeding America so it's a
great initiative and happy to be a part
of it do you drop the kids off
I drop them off sometimes uh I did not
drop them off uh I did not drop them off
today because I had to come you know
kind of get prepare for your show and
had to shave and you know do all this
stuff and you know make sure I'm looking
good and have my stories prepared for
what you might ask uh but you know but I
do I will drop off some days uh or at
least uh you know we have kind of two
different drop-offs and kids are all
different ages so I'll take one of them
or do some pickups so I'm trying to try
to do my part no it's nice but you know
the Giants playing well it it feels like
I'm seeing a lot more people wearing
Giants jerseys than I have in about 10
years Eli they're coming back out
they're coming they're coming back out
have you bought into the giant like is
this real in your opinion and now as an
analyst not as a former giant sure are
they are they for real playoff team I
think I think they're for real just
because they're just playing good team
in football they're finding ways to win
and it's not always like the prettiest
thing the first half but you know it's
like those teams that have something
they're like hey we're a second half
team and and you know they understand
that they're not going to freak out if
they're down a little bit they're not
going to get worried if they're not
playing the greatest at certain times
and they cannot overcome it and you know
we had that uh a little bit in the 07
team we were in a way away game team we
were terrible at home but we would play
great on on the road and went on the
road and you know could make comebacks
and be a fourth quarter team and be a
two-minute Drive team so you have that
um that little little thing that you
feel confident that you're going to be
able to find a way to win
um I think it's a good thing you don't
always wish you had to be a fourth a
second half team you wish hey why can't
we play this way the whole way but if
you have it and you know you know you're
not gonna freak out at times and get
worried during certain circumstances so
um you know I think going against the
team you know Green Bay good team you
know come coming back on them you know
defense stepping up having you know kind
of a a goal line stop there or a Red
Zone stop at the end to win that game
that's a that's a big momentum swing and
you know give some you know some
um you know kind of makes the rest of
their wins look a little bit more valid
have you ever gone as you
at Halloween
I've never gone as me I usually wear the
same not to give it away some of a big
mask guy and so I have like an old man
mask it kind of looks like Freddy
Krueger but I don't think it's Freddy
Krueger I think it's just I think it's
just an old man uh I've also known as
Chucky like a full mask so you know I'll
kind of just I guess I'm going as me I'm
wearing my normal clothes that I would
have been wearing that day but uh uh
just kind of throw my throw my mask on
what about going as Peyton
yeah I could go yeah I think I think
people would figure that out but I could
try that old Denver uniform or I guess
you know maybe Colts maybe throwback
Peyton uh uh Tennessee
well you can't wear Tennessee that's
true but if you're in costume I think I
think you can
it's great to talk to you as always yeah
you're the best pal thank you buddy talk
to you next month that's Eli Manning the
two-time Super Bowl champ and uh visit
quakerhungerclock.com to learn more
about how you can donate feeding America